i'm now going to give you a series of
numbers and i want you to figure out
what the pattern is and then tell me
what the next couple of numbers are
going to be
so let me give you some numbers
so this is
let's say
this number
i have this number
and i have
this number
and i want to know what the next two
numbers in this series are and you might
want to pause it and try it yourself
because i'm about to tell you how to do
this
well let's see
what's happening is we go from
6342 to 6442
what happened well it looks like the
only difference is the three became a
four in the hundreds place
so we had
one more hundred so essentially we added
a hundred here
we added 100 or another way to add 100
is to increment the hundreds digit by
one
and let's see when we went from
6442 to 6542
what happened well the same thing we had
the hundreds digit 4 and we incremented
it by 1 right
when you increment the hundreds digit by
1 right 4 plus 1 is equal to 5
you're actually saying 400
plus 100 is equal to 500 right because
we're operating in the hundreds place so
we've added 100 again
so that looks like the pattern is each
number is 100 more than the one before
it so let's add a hundred again
so how do we add a hundred here
how do we add a hundred to six thousand
five hundred and forty-two
well we just increment the hundreds
digit by one again
so now it is instead of six thousand
five hundred and forty-two it's going to
be six thousand
six hundred and forty-two
we incremented
the hundreds digit by one or added a
hundred and we could just keep going we
could increment it by another hundred
and that's just
adding one to this to the hundreds place
6742
would be the the second number to add
let's do another one
so here's the numbers
so that's six thousand three hundred and
forty two
seven thousand
three hundred and forty-two
eight thousand
three
342
and this pattern very similar to the
previous one but where are we
incrementing right now the 342 stayed
the same
but the thousands are changing
we went from
6000 to seven thousand to eight thousand
so we're adding one thousand every time
right
plus one thousand
plus
one thousand so let's just keep adding a
thousand so how do we do that we
increment the thousands digit
so to add a thousand here
plus one thousand
we'd get nine thousand three hundred
and forty-two now this is interesting
what happens when we add a thousand to
this
well we could say we have 10
1000's
right
and you know it and and when we actually
read it that's essentially how we're
going to read it but the way you should
view this is you can never have 10 in
any one place we can't have a 10 in the
thousands place right so now we're going
to create even a larger bucket or a
larger can and that's called the ten
thousands place and that's going to be
one place over
so now instead of having
9342 when you add a thousand to it
you complete a bucket of ten thousands
so that in that allows us to say well we
have one of this new super huge bucket
called a ten thousand bucket we have one
of those and that's where we put all of
our thousands so now we have
no one thousands left because all 10
were put into that big bucket
and then 342
right
and this is essentially introducing and
i think we've done a couple of problems
with that that place so now we have the
hundreds sorry we have the ones place
that's where the two is the tens place
that's where the four is or 40
the
the hundreds place that's where the
three or the three hundred is
this is the thousands place which you're
familiar with and now this is the ten
thousands place we have one ten thousand
here and the way we would read this is
ten thousand three hundred and forty two
and we added a thousand here
to get here
let's do another one
so let's say i had
we're always starting with 6342
and then let's say we go to
that number
so what are we doing in some ways this
is the simplest right the thousands are
staying the same six thousand six
thousand six thousand three hundreds are
staying the same the forty staying the
same we're just incrementing the ones
place by one every time
and when you increment the ones placed
by one you're just incrementing by one
you're not incrementing by anything
fancier than that so we're adding one
there
adding one again
so what's going to be the next one well
we just add one to the ones place it's
going to be 6345
right adding one to four
and then we have six thousand three
hundred and forty six adding one to
adding one from five to six six thousand
three hundred and forty six let's do one
last problem like this
and every time you see the problem you
should just pause it and try to do it
yourself first that's the best way to
learn
so we're going to start with our classic
6342
and then let's see what the next number
is 6 000.
so what are we doing right we have 6 342
6352 6362
so we're incrementing the tens place
by one
so when we we're adding 10
right when you add 10 you just increment
the tens digit by one we're adding 10.
so the next one is going to be 6300
add one to this digit or adding 10 to
the entire number gives us
72. then we add 10 again we get 6382.
actually let me give you a little
thought experiment what happens if we
keep going what happens if we keep
adding 10 well then we go to 6392
and now this is interesting what happens
when we add 10 here
well we want to increment the tens digit
that's what we're learning so if we just
automatically did that without thinking
our four places would be six thousand in
the thousands place 300 in the hundreds
place 10
in the tens place and then 2
in the ones place well we can't do that
you can't have a 10 you can only have a
digit there you can't actually have a
multiple
digit number in any given place
so once you have a group of 10 in a
given place what you do is you combine
them all up and then you put them into
the next highest place
so this is incorrect
that's incorrect
what you do is you take these 10 and you
say well those 100 those 10 tens are
actually equal to a hundred so you would
go
you would take these
and you'd essentially put them here
so you would add one to the hundreds so
the next number is six thousand four
hundred
and two
all right it also kind of makes sense if
you just look at it visually the six and
the two stay the same the thirty nine
becomes forty
any way that you you find a look at it
that might be easier
let's uh let's go back to some of the
visual
visual ways that we were viewing some of
these problems before so let me ask you
a question what is
let me pick a vibrant bold color
what
is
100
more
than
3624
you might want to pause it and try it
yourself
and i'm going to do it very visually for
you i'm going to draw you the thousands
place
thousands
so how many thousands do we have here
so we go to the thousands place
three thousand right three thousand six
hundred twenty four so let me draw three
thousands
so it's one
two
three
let's do the hundreds place
hundreds
how many hundreds do we have
we go to the hundreds place we have six
hundreds
so that's one
two
three
four
five
six hundreds
all right and i can over let me see i
can write a hundred here in each of
these
100
100
hundred
hundred
hundred
hundred
okay now we're in the tens place
tens place is there we have two tens
so tens
let me draw those out that's one
two tens
ten ten and then finally we have the
ones place
that's there ones
and how many ones do we have
one
two
three
four
you could view these as the top of the
cans of marbles where these would be
much bigger cans or you could even view
them as some type of uh you know
currency or you know if you gamble you
could view these as poker chips where
you know this is the these are one
dollar ten dollars hundred dollars
uh thousands of dollars
one thousand dollars each so this is one
one one one
and this was over here these are each a
thousand one thousand
one
thousand one thousand so what was the
question what is a hundred more than
three thousand six hundred and twenty
four so we're essentially going to add a
hundred to this representation so how do
we add a hundred well we're going to add
one to the hundreds place right we're
gonna add a group of a hundred so let me
add a group of 100
and i'm going to do it here because i'm
going to keep erasing it so if i had a
group of 100 it's going to go into the
hundreds place and i'm just going to add
another group of 100 right there
so now how many hundreds do i have
well i have one two three four five six
seven or 100 200 300 400 500 600 700 so
now i have 700
and everything else stayed the same so i
have
three thousand
right this is three thousands
seven hundreds
seven hundreds
i have two tens so that's two tens or
twenty
and then four ones
twenty
four
so what is a hundred more than three
thousand six hundred and twenty four
it's three thousand seven hundred and
twenty four and we just incremented the
hundreds digit by one
let's do a couple more like that
let me erase this as neatly as i can
so i'm going to do different scenarios
so let's do another series so i'm back
to 3600
and now i'm going to ask you
what is one more
what is one more
than 3624
well if i'm only adding one
i'm essentially adding you know one more
we call it one dollar poker chip
right and that'll go into the ones place
so you would add it down here
it's in the ones place
so now that we have we have three
thousands
we have three thousands
six hundred still all right you can
count them
two tens
and then how many ones we have we added
one chip here one two three four five
so we get three thousand six hundred
and twenty five so we just incremented
or we just increased
the ones place by one to go from a four
to a five three thousand six hundred
twenty five
hopefully you're getting the hang of
this
list oh i didn't wanna erase with the
yellow let's do let's do another one i
just want this to become second nature
to you
let's do another one so what is just
going with the pattern
what is 10 more
than 3 624
well if we're going to add 10 to the
number we're essentially adding a
a 10 denominated chip or you could say a
can of 10 or a group of 10
however you want to imagine it
so where would we add it
well writing 10 so we'll add a group of
10 right here
actually i don't want to do it there
because i want to be able to erase
actually that's fine
that's fine
and then
how many is that that's i've added 10.
so what is my new number
it's three thousand
six hundred
how many tens do i have now well i just
added this one so i have one two three
three tens
so that's 30 and then i have the four
ones still
3634. so when i add 10 to this what did
i just do i just essentially this 2 got
increased by 1 to 3. and why is that
because the 2 counts how many 10
buckets i have and i just added one up
one more to that so that's 3634.
let's do one last problem like this i
this is actually quite enjoyable
i think
so i'm going back to 3624
and now my question is what happens
if i add
1000
so what is one thousand more than three
thousand six hundred and twenty four
well i have to if i'm going to add a
thousand that means i'm going to add a
bucket of a thousand or a can of a
thousand marbles or a poker chip that is
denominated a thousand so i'd put it in
the thousands place
so it would go right there oh that's not
what i wanted to do
let me undo that
it should look like that there you go so
i had a thousands there a thousand a
bucket of a thousand
so now what is the number how many
thousands do i have i had these three i
added one so i have one two three four
thousand
four thousand my hundreds i still have
one two three four five six hundred
i have one two tens
two tens is twenty i have one two three
four
ones
so my new number is four thousand six
hundred twenty four so if someone asks
you what is one thousand more than three
thousand six hundred twenty four it's
four thousand
six hundred and twenty four i'll see you
in the next video